Trascrizione: Sebastiano Inama
Revisore: Federico Sangati
Buongiorno! Buongiorno e grazie.
E niente slide che...
È cuore e passione.
Cuore e passione, perché adesso quando...
In questi giorni parlavamo,
e pensavo ai 15 minuti.
Perché per noi il tempo
è veramente molto importante.
È importante che quotidianamente
condividiamo, parliamo del tempo,
è organizzazione: 10 secondi
cambiano una partita,
una settimana, un mese, una stagione.
Però quando ho visto i 15 minuti
mi sono venuti in mente i 15 anni...
...di Trento. Dalla prima volta, 15 anni.
15 anni: sono l'allenatore
più longevo
su una panchina di serie A, come anni
consecutivi, come anni complessivi.
Ma non è che lo dico per quello.
Lo dico perché...
Perché forse riesce a sottolineare
che tipo di lavoro abbiamo fatto,
che tipo di condivisione c'è stata.
Abbiamo parlato, organizzato,
preso decisioni difficili,
cambiato in corsa,
discusso, diversi ma uguali,
ma sempre parlando di lavoro. Sempre.
Mettendo il lavoro al centro,
mai le persone,
e probabilmente questa cosa qui
ci ha permesso nel tempo,
e per così tanto tempo, di lavorare.
Però lo metto un attimo da parte.
Perché c'è il prima, e venendo qua,
o pensando di venire qua,
per la quarta volta,
perché me le ricordo tutte,
per la quarta volta mi è venuta
in mente la palestrina dell'inizio,
perché ho un percorso un po' differente,
non sono né stato un grande giocatore,
ho solo giocato, e non sono stato
all'interno di un club importante,
"scolarizzato", passatemi il termine,
comunque all'interno di un club
di Serie A,
dove alleni i ragazzi, dove sei
assistente, dove vivi nei corridoi
e senti parlare, comunque respiri l'aria
direttamente, subito, dell'alto livello.
E invece non è stato così.
E venendo qua mi sono venute in mente
queste immagini quattro volte: oggi,
quando siamo andati in Serie A,
vincendo l'ultima partita,
la promozione in Serie A.
Mancavano dieci secondi alla fine,
abbiamo fatto un canestro del +10,
io ho iniziato a correre
perché dicevo ai miei giocatori
di tornare in difesa.
Per fortuna si è alzato
un mio giocatore, mi ha detto:
"Coach, coach! Canestro da undici
non esiste. È finita.
Ce l'abbiamo fatta, tranquillo."
Io, sei secondi cambia il mondo.
Quei sei secondi camminando
mi hanno fatto rivenire lo stesso flash.
La terza volta, entrando in uno
spogliatoio NBA prima di una partita.
L'NBA. L'ingresso, prima sul campo
e poi dentro lo spogliatoio,
con i giocatori NBA seduti intorno.
E un'altra volta
quando ho ascoltato l'inno
da allenatore di una nazionale
al campionato europeo.
In queste quattro volte
ho avuto l'immagine della palestrina
di Ponte san Giovanni a Perugia
e Casteldebole alle porte di Bologna
che mi piace nominarle, non c'erano
neanche le tribune, le panchette.
C'avevo i palloni, siccome il custode
era amico avevo anche la chiave
perché se qualcuno voleva venire
prima o lo chiamavo prima,
se comunque qualcuno voleva
rimanere dopo a migliorare qualcosa
io ero lì, o lo stimolavo a rimanere
o rimanevo con lui.
E lo dico soprattutto
perché sono due città diverse.
Perché ho preso e sono andato.
Ci vuole sempre una persona seria con cui
lavorare, con cui condividere questa cosa.
Per fortuna l'ho trovata, la trovai.
Però sono andato. "Ma dove vai?"
Vado ad allenare. "A che fare?"
L'allenatore. "Ma di mestiere?"
Professionalmente sì,
vediamo cosa succede.
E me le ricordo perché sono immagini
che mi sono rimaste in testa sempre.
Sempre. Perché alla base di tutto
la passione, il sangue che scorreva
nelle vene quando entravo in palestra
e parlavo con questi giocatori.
Tra l'altro per tanti anni
sono stato il più giovane delle categorie,
allenavo coetanei o giocatori
più vecchi, e nelle serie minori,
avendo fatto una trafila diversa,
e avendo anche capito che...
Bisognava vincere per andare su,
bisognava fare qualcosa di diverso
per andare su, perché non era facile.
Come quando ci cercavano diplomati,
milite esenti, automuniti a 21 anni.
Datemi tempo! Però ho capito
che quella cosa lì
era una cosa da fare in questo modo,
e sono riuscito piano piano,
però quel campo lì è stata la scuola,
e ci vuole invece anche dello studio.
Per cui parallelamente...
Perché il gioco evolve,
perché il gioco cambia,
perché comunque non sei stato
con tante persone
che te l'hanno insegnato,
ma le sei andate tu a cercare.
Le sono andate a cercare.
Sono andato nelle palestre, negli uffici,
negli impianti di chi già lo faceva,
di chi già era ad alto livello.
Il giorno prima della partita,
il giorno dopo della partita,
a metà settimana,
dopo un periodo positivo,
dopo un periodo negativo, dopo litigate,
con tanto amore, per capire
cosa e come venivano gestite le persone,
perché la parte emozionale ed emotiva
è fondamentale, è fondamentale,
in ogni momento. Devi andare a prendere
le corde dell'anima delle persone
che lavorano con te,
che hanno tutte comunque un ruolo,
sono tutte importanti,
vogliono tutte essere importanti,
sia come squadra che come staff,
perché anche lo staff tecnico
è fatto di professionisti
unici nel loro mestiere.
Otto persone, otto mansioni diverse,
otto incarichi da mettere tutti insieme
sullo stesso binario, senza però
far perdere la loro personalità.
Non è facile, e credo che...
anzi, lo so, che il campo,
comunque il lavoro sul campo
mi ha dato una grande mano
perché impari anche molto a condividere,
impari ad ascoltare,
facendo alle volte finta di no,
ma impari ad ascoltare, chiedi, ti fai
buttare addosso l'energia dagli altri
perché tu ne devi avere tanta
e per tutti quanti, e hai bisogno
di creare delle condizioni
per cui riceverla.
Lì dipende anche dallo spessore
dei giocatori o dei collaboratori.
Questa cosa qui è stata fondamentale
e secondo me la passione
che abbiamo avuto, mi dispiace ripetere
questo termine ma è veramente così,
è stata alla base anche del rischio.
Forse non mi ha fatto neanche mai pensare
all'incoscienza di prendere, andare.
"Ma dove vai? Con con quali sicurezze?",
se non qualche persona che voleva
e vedeva qualcosa da poter costruire.
Quella passione lì, secondo me
ho avuto la fortuna di condividerla
con chi aveva in mente dove arrivare,
ma aveva una grande qualità
che secondo me,
cioè io me la sono sempre tenuta, riuscire
ad avere degli obiettivi raggiungibili.
Nessuno dimentica "là", dove arrivare.
Ma il primo passo...
Perché sennò si rischia di pensare
al "là", al "laggiù",
e poi ad aspettare "che?",
... non viene da solo.
Piccoli obiettivi durante la strada,
raggiungibili.
Adesso che vedo sette minuti
mi vengono in mente anche i sette anni,
perché questo percorso, sette anni fa,
era lì, eravamo lì.
C'era mezzo metro
e si cascava giù, e si cadeva giù.
Dopo un percorso positivo,
dopo che l'azienda
perché lo sport ha sempre guardato
a come organizzare aziendalmente le cose.
Sempre. Ora c'è un po' di ritorno,
c'è un po' di scambio,
perché lo sport nei suoi equilibri
rappresenta molto la vita vissuta.
Ma noi c'abbiamo sempre guardato
a quell'aspetto aziendale,
e nel momento in cui abbiamo fatto
il primo step
e abbiamo cercato di farne altri,
volevamo essere responsabili
di cinquemila persone intorno a noi.
Volevamo andare in campo dicendo
"È pieno!". Volevo andare in campo dicendo
"Mamma mia, devo stare attento, ho un
patrimonio sotto le mani da valorizzare"
anche perché la nostra scelta, in un
territorio di lavoro e club di trentini
che forse nel DNA hanno quel tipo
di organizzazione, di capacità lavorativa,
era molto importante.
E quando siamo arrivati lì,
la passione, sapendo sempre
da dove eravamo prima,
da dove siamo arrivati,
e che è stata alla base di tutto
ci ha permesso, a un mezzo passo
dal cadere, di spiccare praticamente
l'ultimo salto, l'ultimo volo,
perché poi è stato:
campionato vinto, coppa Italia vinta,
serie A, serie A, Europa, Europa,
palestre e impianti da 20mila persone,
parametri tecnici, economici, di team,
completamente cambiati in un attimo,
un frullatore. Noi, gli stessi.
Noi, evolvere la nostra professionalità,
la capacità di stare insieme
per rimbalzarci delle idee,
sempre con le dovute gerarchie,
senza invadere il territorio degli altri
ma mettendo il lavoro davanti.
Ti vengono in mente sempre
i percorsi precedenti,
perché anche quegli altri spogliatoi
avevano comunque gente
che magari nelle serie minori o lavorava,
o studiava, o comunque erano ex giocatori,
erano mentalità leggermente diverse,
però il denominatore comune era:
"Come faccio a tenerli sullo stesso
binario? Come faccio?"
Adesso la squadra, ora, attualmente,
vive di multiculturalità.
Tosta. Time out.
Tanto ne ho cinque in una partita,
faccio il time out. È importante:
55 secondi per dire due cose intelligenti.
Non è facile, anche perché
bisogna andare veramente a colpire...
Ma noi abbiamo: americano,
messicano, olandese, lettone,
portoghese, argentino,
italiani di varie zone d'Italia.
Cioè non è problema della lingua,
è un problema di come si vive,
di come si offendono, di come gioiscono,
di come parlano, e tu devi dare a tutti
un ruolo, tu devi dare a tutti
un sentirsi importante,
tu devi dare a tutti
l'unicità che rappresentano all'interno
del gruppo, ma un team.
Spalla a spalla,
dove finisco io cominci tu.
Che è un lavoro difficilissimo,
e non è vero che è differente
quando si comincia dalla serie minore,
dalla palestrina, dove i palloni
ce li avevi sulla spalla. Non è vero.
Cambia la professionalità,
cambiano l'esperienza,
ma come la gioia di un risultato ottenuto,
è sempre lo stesso.
Nell'ultima categoria e nella prima
è la stessa, perché è rapportata.
È gioia, è sentire che il lavoro
ha portato frutti.
Altrettanto lo è nel momento in cui
lavoriamo con le persone.
Ovviamente l'aspetto multiculturale
cambia nel momento in cui devi ragionare
e iniziare a pensare e a capire come sono.
Non si può aspettare.
Tu aspetti me, io aspetto te,
non andiamo da nessuna parte.
Dobbiamo trovarci in un punto.
Il punto è il bene di tutti quanti.
Questa cosa qua non può esserci
se è solo razionale,
non può esserci se è solo schematica
e organizzativa, serve una trasmissione
dalle vene, perché poi finisce agli occhi,
perché poi finisce anche nelle intuizioni,
finisce nel riconoscere
quando è il momento di fare una cosa,
e finisce anche
nella non-paura di rischiare.
Uno non può non-cominciare perché è dura,
non può non-cominciare perché sarà dura,
non può non-cominciare perché
"Eh, però se poi non va?"
Ma non se ne parla neanche.
Comincia, lavora, però lo deve...
Deve rendersi conto se è veramente
una cosa che riuscirà a non abbandonare.
Io ci vado a letto, perché veramente,
prima di spegnere la luce uno dice:
"Non la mollo, non la mollo.
Difficoltà o no, non la mollo".
Perché quando entro
e supero la riga del campo,
entro in palestra,
iniziano a muoversi intorno a me,
sento dei brividi addosso
che penso e spero
di trasmettergli
e di poterglieli ancora trasmettere.
Grazie.
(applausi)